aucune autre vol Canadien n'est prévu à
partir de lesrotrum de Wally
sedadies l'avaient dit dès vendredi
comme la trêve ne semble pas tenir un
cartoon la fenêtre des évacuations
aériennes à la se rétrécir de jour en
jour
cependant notre travail n'est pas
terminé et le gouvernement du Canada
travaille avec ses alliés pour trouver
d'autres moyens pour ses citoyens de
quitter le pays
tout point maintenant vers Port Soudan à
plus de 800 km de la capitale mais les
Canadiens qui prendront la route ne
seront pas seuls
le monde entier semble maintenant passer
par la petite ville portuaire pour fuir
le pays
et après des heures sur la dangereuse
route entre cartoon et Port Soudan
l'attente se poursuit aux abords de la
mer Rouge
il a fallu plus de trois jours à cet
étudiant pour arriver au port mais des
convois internationaux sous l'égide des
États-Unis de l'ONU tente maintenant de
s'organiser
pendant ce temps tout commence à manquer
à cartoon de la nourriture aux
médicaments
pour pallier la situation la Croix-Rouge
prépare l'envoi de ce cours humanitaire
vers Port Soudan ce premier chargement
de 8 tonnes comprend du matériel
chirurgical destiné à aider les hôpitaux
locaux et les bénévoles du Croissant
Rouge soudanais à soigner les personnes
blessées lors des combats et si Xavier
savoir fournir Radio-Canada Montréal